[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
Turquía con los 20 años de erdogan en el
poder y las nuevas elecciones que se
presentan este mes de mayo para ello nos
acompañan tres invitados en este estudio
ya les presenton periodista de orión 21
conocedor de Turquía bienvenido
que ha estudiado el sistema político
Turco bienvenida Gracias
periodista y fotógrafo acaba de regresar
de Turquía y va a volver para cubrir las
elecciones en mayo bienvenido Logan Hola
Buenas La Turquía de erdogan 20 años
después de su ascenso al poder hoy
nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
hace 20 años erdogan llegó al poder en
Turquía ahora el presidente Turco espera
obtener un nuevo mandato en las
elecciones presidenciales que se
celebrarán el 14 de mayo pero el
conservador se encuentra en una posición
delicada frente a una posición que ha
logrado Designar un candidato único y
con el foco de la actualidad a un puesto
en el grave seísmo que desbastó el
sureste del país el pasado 6 de febrero
hoy vamos a analizar no solo la
contienda electoral que se le presenta
al presidente Turco sino también como es
la Turquía actual en qué se parece y en
qué se diferencia a la de finales del
siglo pasado repasemos algunas portadas
que nos deja la prensa la prensa turca
como curryyette ya sigue día a día los
movimientos de los sondeos de Cara a las
elecciones y apuntan a que el voto de
los jóvenes puede ser determinante la
revista alemana Esther llama erdogan el
incendiario sobre cómo agita conflictos
con el cálculo de que puedan impulsarle
este reportaje ha aparecido en el
Internacional Explica cómo la cor ha
grabado las consecuencias del sismo del
pasado mes de febrero entre las causas
apunta a la construcción frenética no
conforme a las reglas antisísmicas y de
economist con esta otra portada
cuestiona Los pilares democráticos del
país acechante régimen dictatorial
califica al de robar bueno Chris tras 20
años en el poder esta campaña Sí es por
fin de alto riesgo para erdogan es un
gran riesgo porque por la primera vez en
muchos años hay un verdadero posibilidad
que va a perder las elecciones
presidenciales porque hay una coalición
muy heterogénita pero una coalición de
seis partidos apoyado de fuera del
partido
democrático de los pueblos quien podrán
obtener más que 50% por las elecciones
presidenciales en la primera vuelta y
tal vez también si en la primera no
tienen más que 50 por ciento habrá una
segunda vuelta con una posibilidad que
Hernán pierde las elecciones el
terremoto del 6 de febrero las
dificultades económicas la caída en las
encuestas 20 años después de llegar al
poder edelia se ha pagado la estrella
que tenía el presidente con el
electorado ocurre que en 20 años es el
gobierno de receptártida perdón ha
tenido muchos altibajos ha habido muchos
escándalos de corrupción también ha
habido ataques sistemáticos al sistema
judicial a la prensa todo eso ha venido
debilitando su gobierno al mismo que su
partido y la figura que tiene como
presidente en este momento vemos una
figura muy
debilitada sobre todo ha habido un
impacto muy fuerte a raíz de el
terremoto y cómo se ha descubierto por
esta tragedia los problemas
estructurales que existen en Turquía es
decir no hay un respeto de las leyes de
construcción hay una corrupción muy
grande y sobre todo una una incapacidad
de manejar esta crisis esta crisis
enorme con resultados dramáticos 50.000
personas murieron en el en el en el
terremoto y más de 1070.000 viviendas
fueron destruidas entre casas y
edificios eso definitivamente tiene un
impacto en el electorado de erdoan
porque muchas de esas personas vienen de
las clases social más necesitada que era
la base electoral de de
el terremoto sus ataques a la justicia
la corrupción las dificultades
económicas de todas las causas Cuál es
la que erosionado más A erdogan cuál es
la que más le ponen dificultad Creo que
uno de los asuntos más importantes y
estos si miramos al pasado y los pasados
20 años
Es el cambio de régimen porque estábamos
Bueno antes Turquía estaba en un régimen
parlamentario y erdogan
ahorrando solo con decretos porque es
régimen totalmente presidencial Y eso
creo que es un asunto muy importante
porque entre los años 2000 y los años
2020 la gran diferencia en Turquía es la
gobernancia la crisis económica y el
terremoto son dos de los factores más
importantes porque hay que acordarse que
erdogan en los años 2000 ha sido elegido
justo después del terremoto de Smith y
había dicho que el responsable de tantos
muertos 17.000 no era el terremoto sino
el estado por las construcción las
reglas para sísmicas no respetadas
etcétera y ahora pues hay una
institucionalización total de las
autoridades económicas la crisis
económica es súper fuerte tiene un papel
muy importante en esto así que creo que
todo esto mezclado es resulta de estos
22 años lo vamos a volver a esas causas
Pero antes hablemos de la oposición y
quemalista erdogan Cris quién a ver si
lo digo bien killich si no me ayuda el
kiris y Qué opciones reales tienen
porque hay sondeos que incluso le
otorgan la victoria contra erdogan
qué mal Killers es
el representante
del digamos del yape al partido
republicano de los pueblos es el partido
antigua creado por aquí mal es el
partido del Estado Turco toda siempre ha
sido el partido del Estado Turco con una
posición
antidemocrático contra los kurdos muy
nacionalista pero ahora se vuelve de ser
una una un candidato de una oposición
quien va aglutinar a toda la oposición
anti su política es una política liberal
no es una política
muchas reformas pero visto del punto de
vista de los cursos Es algo es una
persona que puede moderar la política
interior en Turquía podría apoyado con
la izquierda Turco y con sus aliados y
los
apoyados de fuera para los cursos podría
reformar al sistema Turco un poco para
que sea un poco más democrático
liberación de empresas políticas
utilización de la lengua kurda y cosas
no son cosas muy revolucionarios pero
son cosas importantes al interior por la
población en Turquía que sufre mucho de
la política digamos Casi casi
dictatorial Claro pero dirige una
alianza de hasta seis partidos de todo
pelaje político de la derecha
nacionalista hasta la izquierda el
pegamento que une a todos estos partidos
Es simplemente ser antierdogan o dicho
de otra forma esto es suficiente como
amalgama para llegar al poder Delia no
es suficiente pero es una buena
estrategia desde ya para captar estas
seis fuerzas políticas tienen un
objetivo en común que hacer frente para
ganar en las urnas luego no es cierto
que no se parezcan porque igual han
llegado a un acuerdo los seis partidos
desean regresar al sistema parlamentario
que existía antes del 2017 cuando los
poderes del presidente fueron
magnificados a través de un referéndum
también desean
restaurar el estado de derecho decir
plenamente libertad de expresión para
los medios para
las personas en general y
restablecer un diálogo con la Unión
Europea y occidente es decir son tres
puntos bases en los cuales estos seis
partidos se han puesto de acuerdo
Entonces hay un poco más allá de
solamente estar en contra de rodón pero
sobre todo un gran pragmatismo vemos en
esta coalición Logan Claro porque todos
estos partidos y que quieren llegar al
poder y por pragmachismos saben que
solos no no van a alcanzar este objetivo
Así que se unieron después creo que hay
un punto común entre entre estos
partidos es esta esa voluntad de cambiar
de régimen y devolver a régimen pasado
un régimen parlamentario porque arrugan
también anulo la figura del Primer
Ministro Y eso en un país creo que es
algo decisivo
más allá Creo que estos partidos van
bastante divididos dentro de esta
coalición pero la gente que va a votar
para ellos también tiene la historia en
cabeza en memoria y creo que más allá la
que Luque o está uniendo a la gente Hoy
es el sentimiento antiarrugada
claramente
aquí puede recurrir erdogan en esta
situación de dificultad les pongo
ejemplos política exterior la política
exterior turca ese posicionamiento
internacional de intentar ser mediador
por ejemplo en la Guerra de Ucrania
puede beneficiar a erdogan Cris Claro
que sí porque se posiciona como un
árbitro en bastante conflictos como
alivia en Ucrania en Siria Trata de
ser amigos con baseball
Putin a él le gusta bastante entonces a
su su política exterior internacional
juega al papel de un árbitro
puede beneficiar este para obtener fotos
por las elecciones pero su gran problema
es la crisis económica al interior ha
conseguido en cualquier caso restablecer
relaciones con un montón de países no
crisis o Delia
es impresionante porque pues
en el año 2015 por ejemplo estaba rayado
con la mitad de oriente medio Y pues
ahora sí que normalizó con Israel Norma
hizo con Arabia Saudita con los emirates
árabes Unidos con Egipto es un gran
cambio porque también la crisis
económica está afectando tanto al
interior del país que rogan necesita
fondos extranjeros y ha sido una táctica
suya creo que es una táctica buena para
salir esa crisis económica Pues
normalizar con con el universo entero y
ya vemos que en el tablero ucreño
también tiene un papel súper importante
porque se pueden emiliador y fue el
ministro
ruso mismo que el que lo dijo se ha en
negociaciones entre Rusia y Ucrania será
en Estambul o sea ahora sí que se sabe
súper potente en el plan diplomático en
el plan internacional y la misma manera
de intentar salvarse al interior del
país este posicionamiento exterior de
Turquía Delia es el gran aval de erdogan
para estas elecciones definitivamente yo
creo que es en el plan internacional es
el uno de los pocos Campos en el cual
puede mostrar que funciona que está
funcionando muy bien y sobre todo juega
con lo que siempre entre comillas ha
jugado Turquía que es un país
geopolíticamente importante en el mundo
tanto en este momento para Rusia como
para occidente está poniendo en valor su
su posición geopolítica estratégica para
salir un poco a flote de esta crisis
económica que lo viene persiguiendo
después de desde hace varios años
entonces Sí definitivamente la agenda
internacional juega un rol muy
importante en estas elecciones bueno
hace 20 años han pasado mucho mucho de
lo que pasó hace 20 años con el yoguar
erdogan al poder les voy a preguntar a
vuelta de pausa En qué se diferencia la
Turquía actual en la que erdogan busca
la reelección de hace 20 años cuando
llegó por primera vez erdogan al poder
va a ser a vuelta de pausa que en
Primera Plana hasta ahora
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes al programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo
miles de personas cada año se ven
obligadas al Éxodo a huir de sus países
en busca de una vida mejor Llevamos una
mirada humana a la migración masiva en
América Latina y en el resto del mundo
[Música]
acompáñenme en migrantes por France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]
France 24 su ventana al mundo
Lite actuality
en Primera Plana esta semana analizando
la figura de erdogan 20 años después de
su llegada al poder por primera vez y
también las elecciones que se van a
celebrar Precisamente en Turquía el
próximo mes de mayo lo hacemos con los
periodistas Chris de John Delia
runategui y Logan pack piña hace 20 años
erdogan supo combinar las expectativas
de las nuevas clases neuronas no
reconocidas por las élites turcas y el
electorado más rural y conservador los
neuurbanitas ya han cambiado y sus hijos
ya no conectan a erdoan Chris Por qué
sus logros Ya quedan lejanos a las
nuevas generaciones turcas yo me
recuerdo cuando era enviar al final de
los años 90 el movimiento
islamista alrededor de rifa partido
ahora akp era en la oposición y los que
tuvieron el poder en Turquía era el
llave ahora en la oposición
y al movimiento curva era bastante
increíble o
pero no no era tan urbanizado Ahora hay
una realmente verdadero Urbanización
de los de la gente toda la gente en
Turquía y Hay también una gran
fortalecimiento no solamente del
movimiento curdo pero también de la
izquierda turca hay algo alrededor de
este partido porque hay que comprender
que todavía siempre hay tres grandes
bloques en Turquía un bloque islamo
conservador alrededor del akp Aliado
ahora con la extrema derecha
de los republicanos quemalistas con sus
aliados y la tercera fuerza alrededor de
los cursos los cursos ahora tienen más
que 10 12% del electorado más que 50 60
por ciento en la región kurda es una
fuerza política no solamente es una
fuerza militar de alpiqui cuando porque
son son ligados a los terroristas del de
los trabajadores están ahora la Express
la expresión política del movimiento
kurda ligado a la izquierda
turca y al movimiento lgbt tiene una
realmente
la tercera fuerza en Turquía que va a
jugar un papel de árbitro en las
próximas elecciones Ah pues Antes de
hablar de jóvenes Cómo es la relación de
los kurdos con esa oposición que puede
quitarle el poder a erdogan Logan porque
parece un poco ambigua no esa relación
es complicada es complicada porque no
forman parte de esta coalición de seis
partidos por varias razones pero se
necesitan no forman parte pero se
necesitan al mismo tiempo porque es un
juego muy sutil los kurdos en las dp Ha
sido la tercera fuerza política a las
últimas elecciones vale más de 6
millones de votantes o sea un partido
decisivo
en la oposición Pues en ahí también
partidos muy nacionalistas como el
hiperchi por ejemplo Y estos no quieren
nada que ver con los kurdos no quieren
hacer una coalición con ello pues si no
se van así que los cursos estaban
obligados de quedarse fuera de esta
coalición Pero había muchos
negociaciones debajo de la mesa a ver
qué futuro para los kurdos qué quieres
Dark Blue puede hacer para la lengua
escurra qué crisis puede hacer para los
presos kurdos que son miles y miles en
las dp tiene más de 4.000 presos ahora
mismo pues esos están negociando debajo
de la mesa Pero saben y Chris del blues
sabe perfectamente sin el boto kurdo
Será muy difícil de ganar Así que es
puro pragmatismo entre estas dos partes
a ver si las consignas de voto de las dp
van a ser respetadas por sus aficiones
aficionados y ya veremos pero si es un
paso decisivo que este que se está
jugando ahora Delia hoy Turquía
diferencia de ese país de hace 20 años
Que haciendo ya la comparativa es un
país organizado al 75%, el voto urbano
decide y Hacia dónde se inclina más bien
ese voto urbano exactamente es decisivo
contra el pronóstico de erdoandt no es
favorable para el akp porque durante
estos 20 años ha habido un recambio
generacional los jóvenes de ahora
solamente han conocido en el gobierno
akp erdoan y no están contento no están
contentos porque hay una
forma de censura
a la libertad de prensa a la libertad de
expresión tienen miedos que por un tuite
puedan terminar en la cárcel Entonces
los jóvenes urbanizados más educados que
hace 20 años quizás
no están con una tendencia a favor de
votar por acapé a decir verdad están con
una tendencia al opuesto
pese a las dificultades de esta
reelección erdo cuenta con otras
herramientas para mantenerse en el poder
hablamos de esos contra poderes que en
Turquía ya no lo son tanto como la
prensa libre o la justicia no Cris como
destruyendo contra poderes controla al
90% de las medias
ha cerrado la gran gran gran parte de
las medias críticas como
televisión era la gran televisión de la
oposición ahora no existe Pero hay
el red social a Facebook todo eso existe
Pero también es muy controlado la gente
no Son estúpidos tampoco no creen
siempre lo que dicen las medias otra
gran problema es que si hay una
diferencia de tres cuatro por ciento
entre airloham akpi y la mesa de seis él
podría tomar medidas de provocación de
terror de fraude Hay un gran posibilidad
de fraude por eso al movimiento popular
llama para enviar observadores para
observar las elecciones
en dificultad
es posible que no va a respetar el juego
legal Cómo ha ido evolucionando el islam
en la sociedad turca en estos 20 años de
erdogan Logan
hay que entender que
la capa es un partido islamo conservador
tampoco el islam es muy presente pues es
más una manera es un mensaje que está
dando a los más religiosos al interior
mismo de Turquía pero no es no es algo
tan potente como lo podemos ver desde
fuera a veces creo que el factor
nacionalista es mucho más importante que
el factor religioso en Turquía y por eso
hemos visto el cambio A partir de los
años 2015 en los que erdogan hizo una
gira total a la derecha se alió con el
partido de extrema derecha del mhp y
ahora mismo el factor nacionalista es un
impulso para su campaña y porque sabemos
que en Turquía Obviamente
históricamente el factor racionalista es
muy importante Por eso yo este paso pero
el factor religioso no es tan importante
como lo vemos en cualquier caso tanto el
factor nacionalista como el religioso
como el más de esa deriva conservadora
le ha desconectado de los jóvenes es que
ha habido un viraje en su ideología
política al comienzo comenzó con un
partido de Centro derecha bastante
abierto cuando era amigo de Europa en
aquel momento en el que se llegaba a
hablar de Turquía que entrar en la unión
presentará la candidatura de entrada en
la Unión Europea Cuánto ha llovido de
aquello no y al pasar pocos años dos
tres años hizo el cambio a
islamo conservador bastante marcado y
después ha vuelto a girar hacia un
nacionalismo nacionalismo que por las
alianzas le conviene bajar el discurso
religión en la política Entonces ha
habido una mutación en la ideología del
partido yo creo que eso también puede
desestructurar un poco la base de sus de
los que votaban por él porque ya no se
reconocen en el en el partido
cuando hablamos de personalidades como
Putin hablamos siempre de la visión que
tienen de la Rusia de futuro para
entender las claves de lo que pasa en
Ucrania si hablamos de la visión de
erdogan de cómo creen que quiere que
pase su legado en el futuro de Turquía
qué dirían la visión que tiene del
futuro de Turquía erdogan una figura que
también tiene megalomanía como en el
pasado una un país una bandera un pueblo
extremamente nacionalista sin respeto
por la divergencia es lo contrario de
los demás yo pienso que un cambio de
presidente un derrota de Adán dará un
increíble burbuja de aire para la el
movimiento social en general en Turquía
en el asunto en los asuntos exteriores
hay que acordarse que el Roland mando
tropas en Libia en Siria que sigue un
rollo terrible en el ucarrabás pues está
en muchos frentes y en Irak también
ahora mismo se ve que hay ataques casi
diarias sobre los kurdos en Irak Así que
creo que
se arrogan deja el poder va a hacer un
gran no solamente al nivel nacional como
lo dijo muy justamente Chris pero
también el nivel internacional desde
occidente sin duda subrayamos ese
elemento identitario nacionalista de
erdogan también para subrayar las
diferencias con el padre fundador de la
nación con adaturk Pero eso no nos puede
hacer caer en análisis simplista decir
el resultado es una tendencia analizar
la política turca únicamente en términos
de enfrentamientos entre las visiones
quemalista y erdoganista o entre turcos
laicos y conservadores y puede haber más
matices entre medias Qué les parece
Delia yo creo que a decir verdad estas
dos figuras políticas turcas han
cultivado lo que se llama el culto a la
persona claro ha sido alrededor también
un hiperpresidencialismo ahí también
ciertas cosas que los que los acercan
para una comparación en ese sentido
después erdoan yo creo que se ha perdido
en el curso de la ruta y lo que ha que
lo que él siempre ha querido dejar es un
legado
importantísimo rey de regresar a un
pasado otomano y dar una identidad nueva
a Turquía yo creo que está en la mitad
del camino y en este momento se Se ha
perdido en el camino en eso también hay
alguna comparativa con Putin en el de
Volver al imperio pasado con Esa visión
de futuro no Logan claro y más Más allá
de eso Si erdogan deja el poder ahora
mismo para él sería un drama Sin nombre
porque quiere dejar un vuelo muy fuerte
desde desde que llegó al poder y se nota
cada día ahora mismo dejaría el país con
una con una crisis económica muy grande
después de un terremoto que mató a más
de 50.000 personas y en el que tiene un
papel bastante importante por lo que
hemos hablado antes así que para él se
haría una humillación terrible de dejar
el poder ahora mismo por eso se supone
que en el mes que queda antes de las
elecciones todo puede pasar y arrugan ve
a intentar todo lo que pueda para
mantenerse al poder y si está derrotado
pero de tres o cuatro por ciento podemos
imaginar que va a intentar todo también
para cancelar estas elecciones Como hizo
justamente en el año 2015 hay que
acordarse que perdió las legislativas y
pues hizo otras elecciones seis meses
después y entre estas dos elecciones el
país cayó en un infierno dos atentados
una guerra en el sureste Pues un rollo
terrible Así que podemos pensar que el
futuro es súper súper incierto hay
peligra este tipo de derivas en según
los resultados Cris absolutamente sí y
yo quiero también clarificar que de la
parte de los cursos o de la izquierda
turca o del movimiento que apoyan a la
tercera fuerza No hay ninguna ilusión
será más o menos lo mismo pero una
pequeña apertura democrático una
restitución de alcaldes destituido por
erdoham en los últimos años sería una
pequeña diferencia que les permita de
nuevo hacer la política popular
Muchísimas gracias a los tres ha sido un
placer estaremos muy atentos a lo que
pasa en esas elecciones en el próximo
mes de mayo y a todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana quien en Primera Plana
gracias